this is a Fox News Alert the illegal
immigrant wanted for killing a police
officer in California arrested after a
massive 48-hour manhunt the sheriff in
charge of the investigation
blaming sanctuary laws saying the
suspect had two previous DUI arrests and
if he had been reported Officer Ron
Singh would still be alive
authorities also saying the suspect had
known gang affiliations and was trying
to flee to Mexico the slain officer was
shot and killed during a traffic stop on
Wednesday morning
two others have also been arrested for
helping the suspected murderer evade
capture
police announcing the arrest at an
emotional press conference with the
officers family watch I am pleased and
very proud of the fact that the suspect
is in custody
he has been apprehended in Bakersfield
he was safely taken into custody earlier
today by teams from the Kern County
Sheriff's Office and many other law
enforcement agencies who have helped us
relentlessly pursue this suspect in
pursuit of justice
Gustavo Perez Arriaga 33 years old again
was arrested earlier today during the
execution of a search warrant he was
found at a residence in the Bakersfield
Kern County area and we'll get into the
specifics of that first I want to
introduce officer Ron Singh's brother
Reggie he'd like to share a few words
with all of you please bear with me this
is not easy for me we're gonna sing was
my older brother yes he's not coming
back but there's a lot of people out
there that misses it and a lot of law
enforcement people that I don't know
don't work days and nights to make this
happen
I'd like to thank you for the bottom of
my heart to make this happen I wish I
could thank all the law enforcement
agencies homeland secure
in San Francisco everyone thank you
thank you working day and night
absolutely devastating so Greg what does
this do to our conversation right now
about immigration and the border wall
well I mean first of all the it is
obviously tragic but it's also
infuriating it's infuriating because it
was wholly preventable if you stick to
the facts it's an illegal who entered
the country illegally obviously illegal
he was part of a notorious street gang
he had a couple of arrests and he
murdered a police officer on Christmas
Day
now you could posit the notion that
illegal immigrants are less violent than
the than the legal population or the
people born here that's fine but you
know more Americans die from heart
disease than from cancer that doesn't
mean you don't fight cancer okay so
that's that argument goes away the fact
is if you had prevented his illegal
immigration you would have a police
officer a good good man who is still
alive second part and that leads to the
the media will accuse of people like us
of using a tragedy in order to impact
political discourse well when did we
learn that from right after every
natural disaster it's linked to climate
change after every mass shooting it's
linked to lack of gun control
when did the child of an illegal
immigrant attempts to cross the country
and ends up in the hospital that's
because we're a cold heartless country
who didn't treat these these people
correctly so we've learned this and it
made me that makes me think that perhaps
we should be using these tragedies we
what else can we do is if we see that
this is wholly preventable then what's
really infuriating it happened while
we're having this discussion we've been
having this rolling discussion for two
years about this and it happened if only
someone had listened to it before he
would be alive so that's what it's an
it's something that just people go oh
this is a pelear using this or politics
no this is actually evidence that
something has to be done right I think
what we've seen this week with this case
with one of the cases Greg mentioned of
one of the children who had died in
custody Kate Steinle in San Francisco
just the countless stories of people who
go to great physical dangers to come to
this country is that the lack of an
immigration policy that works in this
country is incredibly tragic and
heartbreaking and it has tragic
consequences that ripple in so many
different ways and when I said let me
ask you one specific question what do
you say to the people who argue that
sanctuary cities
oftentimes protect people just like this
not hard-working immigrants who are
doing whatever they can to get a
foothold in this country and make lives
better for themselves and for their
families but for people like this who
have prior arrests who shouldn't have
been in the country especially after
putting other people's lives at risk
with DUI arrests and you know they
essentially are shielded what do you
fear is what I would say we need to take
a look at everything and try and figure
out what some solutions would be is a
border wall actually something that
would be a solution there are
Republicans like will heart heard from
Texas a congressman who actually says it
wouldn't be a good solution there are
smart people who do not believe this is
the right solution is cracking down on
sanctuary cities something that would
have an evidence-base demonstrable
impact I don't know the answer I'm not
an expert but what's so frustrating
about this shutdown is we are obsessed
with this one thing the wall can we get
daca for the wall which I actually think
are some wall funding which I think
would be a good trade-off but the
broader picture here is the wall the
right thing what world is sanctuary
cities play what should we do with daca
what about visa overstays which is a
huge problem these big issues are not
being tackled right now and and that is
what is really tragic in all of this we
could bog down in the day to day both
sides go to equal extreme opposites and
nobody is willing to come to the middle
but I think part of the reason why is
because I believe a lot of Democrats are
being disingenuous when it comes to the
wall we have reached the point of two
things we know that Mexico is not going
to pay for the wall and that we're not
gonna have a wall or over the entire
border that's not gonna happen
both sides know that's not gonna happen
we know that the president is gonna get
some type of border security and we're
gonna we're going to talk about border
security in just a little bit but you
know let's talk about this officer
because this is tragic and you know this
this happens at Christmastime and it's
every every law enforcement family and
the country feels that pain because
that's your biggest fear is that the
person that you love who wears the
uniform to keep other people safe is not
going to come home his family is
devastated his department is devastated
are we having the right kind of
conversation about that I think that's
that's a great point too when you look
he has a five-month-old and just
watching the video of the people who
work with him the office who officers I
think a lot of times people forget that
these law enforcement officials they are
really a family and they go out there
every single day and they risk their
lives for us and when you see their
reaction they there is a component of
this that is preventable there is no way
that you could watch this and somehow
step back and defend sanctuary cities I
mean that is a part of the conversation
that should not be happening there are
good people on both sides of the debate
about immigration you want to talk about
comprehensive reform you don't want to
talk about the wall you make good point
some people feel maybe the wall isn't
the best route or maybe the wall isn't
the only route it has to be coupled with
other things but you're gonna watch this
and somehow defend a sanctuary city that
defies federal law and mayor's like the
mayor of Oakland who comes out and
lambaste ice and and and says to to its
residents you know what I'm gonna give
you a warning to protect you from ice
Border Patrol agents have been vilified
ice has been vilified and there are
people in this country who are a known
risk who have a known record and they
are being allowed to exist here and you
have to prevent these people from being
able to get here and from not being held
accountable yes they're doing III think
you know part of what Marie is saying is
that you do need a better system right
and and the government has failed this
utterly in terms of immigration because
people like that should not be in the
country people like that who want to
hurt people and and so easily take
someone's life because this guy knows
that if he was arrested he would have
been deported it would have been his
third DUI arrest and he's got a gang
affiliated tattoo on his arm and he
hears a dude the crimes like this can
happen if you take a political or
symbolic stance at them at the risk of
the citizens it's like a sanctuary city
is
essentially a risk that you place on
citizens for a symbolic gesture it's a
symbolic virtue signal hey we care we're
not like Trump or not like the rest of
everybody else we care come to our
cities
never mind that that actually elevates
risks so the whole thing is a travesty
because it's designed to actually make
certain people feel better while you pay
the price when the media covers this
though you had to sift through when I
was looking at the headlines of this
story you had a sift through paragraph
one article paragraph seven you had to
get to before they said that this person
was here illegally and then you have the
parallel of Trump being vilified every
day for talking about a wall for
prioritizing border security for talking
about drug trafficking for talking about
gang violence we know they came in
through an illegal port of entry though
I think I don't know that I think the
details are still emerging here what all
of this is tragic right like a police
officer getting killed by a citizen is
also tragic we have to look at how
things are preventable and how we fix
the system and I think that both sides
are very good at vilifying the other you
know I am these children that are dying
in DHS custody this has to stop that was
in a hospital wasn't it the second one
well when is that custody I guess
technically it's custody but it's also
people trying to save their lives in
order to stop that used to claim the
board that's how you stop it because you
stop incentivizing people to go to be
Khalifa candy no together legal under
our laws apply showing up and applying
for asylum it's still legal if we want
to make that illegal we can change the
laws but my point is these the
immigration system in our country needs
fixing it needs snow just to come across
the border system so why is it Nancy
Pelosi saying the first thing we are
going to do is fix immigration the first
thing I say they're going to do is shove
the shutdown in the president's face to
show that they are resisting resisting
is not fixing immigration so and
figuring out how to get good people in
the country and the right number of
people who can fill the jobs that are
critically I say tricked aren't getting
paid today though because of the
shutdown but you know you know we spent
the last we spent the last three weeks
we had the I was at times man of the
year a person words of the journalist
the Journal
those that are in danger under Trump's
America we've seen a 12% increase in
police killed in the line of duty it was
from 2018 to 2017 it was like 144 have
been killed that's where the risk is
when it comes to every one of these
stories no matter how political is it's
the guy who gets there first gets shot
well we're gonna get somewhere first and
that is the government shutdown